Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David P. Here
is a voicemail from again, someone who completely
misunderstood everything I've said. I just I must
really be a terrible communicator. Let's listen.
Speaker 6: Hello, J.B.. I really feel bad for you
right there when you describe the options
that you're exploring. That last one with
Poland and Belarus. That sounds like the long
shot of the three. How far have you considered
a fourth option? Maybe somewhere in Spain or
Italy? Oh God. Since you're fluent in Spanish
and other Spanish speakers in Italy, why not
Spain or Italy? Have you thought about that?
Speaker 1: I never said that moving to Poland or
Belarus is anywhere on my list. When someone said,
David, what's your escape plan? If the
U.S. becomes authoritarian? I explained,
because I was born in Argentina, I can go back
to Argentina any time. That's an option. I could
go to Israel, and I believe it's within about a
year. I could get citizenship there. The third
option I mentioned is because I have a lineage
to Poland family that fled Poland before the
Holocaust. There is a law which if you can prove
that lineage, you can get a European passport. OK,
I explained the part of Poland my family was from
is now Belarus, so I'm not thinking of moving
to Belarus or Poland. I was explaining that the
documents I need might be in what is now Belarus,
or they might be in what is now Poland. But
the point would be just to get the European
passport. And with that I would have my pick. And
yes, of course, I would probably end up either
in Spain because I speak Spanish in France,
my friends, my French is good enough and I
really like France. Sure, Italy. But but
I'm not thinking of moving to Poland and
certainly not thinking of moving to Belarus,
which is not even I wouldn't even be able to,
because it's totally, totally different thing.
I hope, I hope I've been more clear today.
We have a great bonus show for you today. Israeli
data suggests a fourth COVID shot is unlikely for
most people. Now the important thing is a fourth
one of the one we have. What about an AMR run
shot? That's a different story, and we're going to
talk about that on today's bonus show. Number two,
the U.S. Supreme Court is going to be hearing a
challenge to race-conscious college admissions.
These are elements of affirmative action.
We're going to talk about a big, big case.
And lastly, it shouldn't surprise us. After
Republicans all voted against Joe Biden's COVID
stimulus, they took credit for getting people
money and after voting against Joe Biden and
Democrats infrastructure bill, they are now
taking credit for that infrastructure bill.
Predictable all on today's bonus show. Sign up
at join Packman dot com to get instant access.